Hey!
You're home early.
They let us out of work
'cause there was a shooting.
Why are you
all sweaty?
I was just--
I was working out.
Yeah, is there something
you wanna tell me?
You're beautiful.
Anything else,
anything...
on your mind?
Nope, no, why?
Because what are these,
Kevin?
( bells jingling )
I don't know,
what are those?
They look
like clown panties.
Why are there
clown panties
crumpled up in
our hallway?
Are those not yours?
No, they're not mind.
Do they look like
the hypoallergenic brand
my doctor recommended?
No!
They look like they
belong to a clown.
A slut, whore clown!
( bells jingling )
Okay, you know, I--
I think I know what that is.
I did our laundry at
that new Laundromat
up the street,
Big Top Laundry.
A lot of local clowns
go there, so...
Hey, I'm glad
I worked this out, huh?
No.
Uh, who's Sparkles?
Hmm?
Sparkles?
I went through your
phone last night.
Here,
let's take a look.
"You up?"
"I need you."
"Honk-honk."
That's the type
of shit
you text to a clown!
Oh!
You are fucking!
Oh, my God, I was just
texting a friend from work!
I can't believe you
took my phone!
You work with someone
at Deloitte & Touche
named Sparkles?
Yes, Sparkles Biederman!
He's been there
for years.
He's Dutch.
"Your ass is tighter
than a balloon giraffe."
You text that to a man
you work with
at a financial
consulting firm?
It's industry jargon.
It's not in your
wheelhouse.
You know what,
this is stupid.
Let's just look at
the security footage
from last night.
How about that?
Oh, my God!
You are being
so crazy right now!
( laughing )
What the fuck
is that, Kevin?
( bells jingling )
( laughing )
Okay.
You got me.
It was supposed
to be
a surprise for
our anniversary.
Our anniversary?
It's tomorrow.
You forgot,
didn't you?
Oh, my God.
I totally forgot.
I'm such a stupid
dumb bitch.
I know how you like
balloon animals
so I paid
these clowns to...
fill your closet up
with them.
( sighing )
Surprise.
I'm so sorry.
Why do you
put up with me?
Because you're hot.
( whispering )
Thank God.
I'm so sorry.
I just-- I get
so scared of losing you.
I know, I know,
I know, I know.
( bells jingling )